نعم لا عجب أيها الذئب هذا أول
رد فعل قادم في تغريدة من
الرئيس
أه تقول ويمكنني أن أقرأها لك
تقول أريد أن أشكر إميلي مورفي في gsa
على تفانيها الثابت
وولائها لبلدنا تعرضت
للمضايقة والتهديد والإساءة
ولا أريد أن أرى هذا يحدث
لها مع عائلتها أو
موظفي gsa ، قضيتنا مستمرة بقوة ،
وسوف نواصل الكفاح
الجيد وأعتقد أننا
سننتصر مع ذلك في
مصلحة بلدنا ،
أوصي بذلك إميلي وهي
يقوم الفريق بما يجب القيام به
فيما يتعلق
بالبروتوكولات الأولية وقد طلبت من
فريقي أن يفعل نفس
الشيء المثير للاهتمام في اثنين من
التهم الأولى هو
أن الرئيس في الوقت الحالي
يبدو أنه يُظهر بعض
الانفتاح على هذا الانتقال.
إلى الأمام
أه أعتقد أنه من بعض الملاحظات أه هذا
ليس بيانًا قتاليًا
من الواضح أنه ليس على اتصال بالواقع
عندما يقول أعتقد أنه سينتصر
وهكذا
أه لكنه يظهر بعض الانفتاح  لا ننسى
هذه الفترة الانتقالية التي
تبدأ أه وتعاونت وكالة الأمن القومي
مع فريق بايدن الانتقالي ،
سأخبرك أن وولف
الثاني تحدث للتو مع أحد كبار مسؤولي البيت الأبيض
في
الدقيقتين الماضيتين الذي قال إن هذا
الخبر
كان مفاجأة للبعض في الداخل  المبنى
أه يتعلمون هذا لأول
مرة على
CNN وأنت تعرف بينما قال هذا المسؤول من
الواضح أن هناك موظفين
مثل هذا الشخص سيتعاون
مع فريق بايدن الانتقالي
أه هذا الشخص لا يمكنه التحدث نيابة عن
الجميع في المبنى ولكن هذا
من الواضح أن هذا مؤشر قادم
من وكالة الأمن القومي على أن هذا الانتقال من
إدارة واحدة الإدارة الرابحة المنتهية ولايته
إلى إدارة اللدغة القادمة قد
بدأ